embattled chinese real estate developer
evergrande's financial crisis continues
to deepen the company on tuesday
revealed that lenders have seized two
billion dollars worth of deposits from
one of its subsidiaries evergrande also
said it won't be able to file its 2021
annual results on time trading in the
company's shares have been halted since
monday
chinese real estate developers are
having a fire sale to bring some
desperately needed liquidity back to
their balance sheets
that's according to chinese media and at
the forefront is evergrand
the property developer with the highest
mountain of debt worldwide
evergrand is over 300 billion dollars in
the red
and it's not the only chinese real
estate developer sinking in debt
china fortune land development ivanka
kaisa shimao fantasia holdings the list
is long
investor worries are growing about
china's property market
and economists warn if evergrand goes
down it could take other companies with
it
and that could cause the chinese people
to lose their faith in real estate as an
investment product
until now private investors have put up
to three quarters of their savings in
apartments and houses
and that's responsible for around a
third of china's current gdp
which is why economists say if the
sector falters it could send china into
a
recession earlier i asked our taipei
correspondent sunghansu what evergren's
debt problems mean for china's economy
china ever grant is the most indebted
real estate development in china with
debt equivalent to more than 300 billion
dollars
of june 2021 the fact is that hidden
debt is a problem in the chinese real
estate industry off-balance sheet debts
that were not previously disclosed to
investors or credit rating companies
such as guarantees for
wealth management products or private
loans have caught investors off guard it
shows that mainland china's real estate
sector has expanded to the limit and the
two
next two major crisis are debt and
bubble cleaning so we could see this
crisis spreading to other top real
estate companies and leaving their huge
debt to this to the state can the
chinese government stop the crisis
well experts are still arguing if the
chinese government will save evergreen
if you remember last year the chinese
communist party set up three red
deadlines for financing the real estate
sector since then the ccp has been
preparing for the bankruptcy of
companies like evergrand the authorities
were asking local governments to prepare
for the possible collapse of our grant
group as long as the crisis does not
impact china's financial stability for
the chinese government it's a good
opportunity to let state-owned
enterprises acquire evergrants good
assets at a favorable price there's news
that other holdings have been asked to
purchase evergreen's assets so rather
than stopping the crisis many predict
the chinese government will use the
crisis to achieve its goal
in taipei thanks so much
you